let's try to squeeze one more Colin if
we can we will go to the 202 area code
caller from 202 tell us what's on your
mind
hey Washington DC area alright and in
the area that you know what the tax cuts
and everything there are tons of ads on
both sides talking about a tax cut maybe
on the Republican side how tax cuts are
increased wages I was thinking what
would it be a good idea for Democrats to
push and independent to like push the
idea that okay if you're saying these
tax cuts which I assume are going to
pass the schematics behind it to be
figured out by the Republicans but I
assume in the past they keep saying it's
going to raise minimal raise wages yeah
what if we tie a minimum wage raising
ill the tax cuts to say okay you say
it's going to raise wages well let's see
your hand
are you really for raising wages where
you're just gonna keep this money well
no there's were there further wages they
would say listen it wouldn't work for
two reasons one is that they would just
never agree to it they'll put an
Obamacare mandate repeal in the tax cut
bill but they won't put anything about
the about wages in there but they would
argue that they don't want to nor do
they believe that they need to mandate
the increase in wages they will argue
that the trickle down effect which of
course doesn't exist and it's been
completely debunked will naturally
increase the available wages and where
you're right is that there's zero
economic analysis or historical data
that suggests that that's the way it
works nor is it even remotely intuitive
so so I think that the caller is right
Pat in terms of that it wouldn't work
but that wouldn't be something that the
Republicans would agree to and then
maybe you have you run the risk of
centrist Democrats like joe Manchin and
Dianne Feinstein joining the honest
signing onto that bill because gonna
raise the minimum wage
maybe so yeah I think it's a bad idea
but I don't think that Republicans would
agree would agree to it anyway but it's
an interesting question nonetheless glad
you're thinking about it all right okay
no problem
all right very good let's take a break
great calls this
really really good calls we will take
calls again although next week it'll be
on the Wednesday show not the Friday
show because of this thing this very
important thing called Thanksgiving or
as we will find out about next week
vegan Thanksgiving more on that next
week